and the salt lake tribune says
protesters called for the firing of a
detective who tried to arrest a nurse
in the middle of an emergency room
dramatic video shows the detective
dragging alex wubbles away after she
refused to let officers take blood from
an unconscious patient
two officers are now on paid
administrative leave
tony decouple is here with why the nurse
says she was just trying to do her job
tony good morning good morning the salt
lake city police department is facing
criticism for its conduct in the video
which was released by alex wubble's
attorneys the footage has resulted in a
public apology from the salt lake city
police chief and a criminal
investigation by the da's office
[Music]
a body camera captured the moment nurse
alex wubbles was arrested in the burn
unit at the university of utah hospital
she was handcuffed after she refused to
let police draw blood from an
unconscious man in the emergency room
i'm just a nurse trying to protect the
patient believe it or not i'm trying to
protect him too it's so blatantly
obvious what was right and what was
wrong and i was not wrong
the victim an idaho reserve police
officer who works as a truck driver had
been brought in after being in this
fiery car crash on july 26 near salt
lake city
officer jeff payne's written report said
he wanted to take a blood sample to show
the victim did nothing wrong is this
patient under arrest nope wubbles
explained to paine that it was against
hospital policy and the law to take
blood as evidence from an unconscious
patient without a warrant or an arrest
she puts her supervisor on speaker
speakerphone
that's when things escalated no we're
done
we're done you're under arrest wubbles
was detained for about 20 minutes before
being released salt lake city police
chief mike brown i was alarmed by what i
saw
in the video the department is
conducting an internal investigation and
has changed its blood draw policy i want
to just continue the conversation we
need re-education and i will be waiting
to hear what chief brown decides should
be done with his
employees over the weekend around 100
people gathered outside police
headquarters to voice their outrage
wubble says if she had to she would take
the same action again
my co-workers would have done the exact
same thing this is what we do this is
our profession
alex wubbles hasn't taken any legal
action but she says that's not off the
table the police department where the
patient worked issued a statement
thanking the nurse and the hospital
staff saying protecting the rights of
others is truly a heroic act it's a
great story for americans to know that
somebody would protect what's really
important your blood from somebody who
doesn't have a warrant a great ending to
a very uh unfortunate beginning yeah i
think we're all shaking our heads
looking at that video over and over
again how can that happen absolutely
tony thank you very much